je vous trouve très for dis les gens sur
les réseaux sont extrêmement choqués par
ton t ta position c'est vrai voilà il y
a éormément gens est choqu par par les
propos de G ver lesqu lesquel
précisément tout ce que tu dis là il
disent
queou qu'il fasse que 8 mois de prison
parce que tu dans la lo la base il dev
pas aller en
prison content parce que à la base comme
il
était du coup il va aller que 8 mois
donc c'est pour ça que en compar
immédiate parce que ça date de très peu
de temp souvent ici on dit le délai est
irrespirable entre l'action et le
jugement là ça a été assez rapide et
puis Cyrille s'il y avait pas
l'obstination de gens de personnes
humaines comme nous juge psychiatre il
serait dehors parce qu'on dit il serait
en hôpital psychiatrique hôpital
psychiatrique excusez-moi je connais par
cœur on peut s'en barrer on peut partir
on peut faire n'importe quoi là au moins
il a une période sur les bord c'est tout
ce que je
dis pe
pe faudra tu comprenn un jour que si la
criminalité augmente autant en France
c'est parce que plus personne n'a peur
des sanctions qui sont donné au tribunal
plus personne n'a peur maintenant tu
fais un truc comme ça tu prend un an un
an et il va sortir comme comm on l'a dit
au bout de 6 mois au bout de 5 mois plus
personne ça ne fait plus peur à personne
de commettre un braquage de squatter de
d'enlever quelqu'un tu as plus peur main
d'utant plus que Gill vient de dire que
lui-même dans un an il a peur qu'il
sorte il a peur de savoir comment il va
c'est scandaleux il plus que ça on va
Voiry qui est fou c'est que la justice
rendu au nom des Français mais il y a
pas un Français qui trouve ça normal
pour moi c'est un danger public et en
plus pour moi la justice française
limite ça donne envie de faire ce genre
de truc parce que soit il se passe rien
soit même quand il se passe des trucs et
ben quand je vois des tikt par exemple
les prisonniers sont là ils ont leur
téléphone ils font des plats mais moi je
pas faire les plats qu'ils font gen ils
sont tranquilles donc c'est n'importe
quoi aprè ça dépend des peines il y a
des voilà il a a des détenus la prison
c'est pas le club non plus j'ai beaucoup
de
PO non plus pour voilà mais je je peux
vous dire même les détenus que je
connais les potes à moi qui sont PL
quand qui voit ça ce garsl je peux vous
dire dis
luii lui c'est pas bon lui c'est pas bon
du tout lui je te le dis voilà je te le
dis voilà oui déjà ce mec ce que disait
C ce mec va être à l'isolement à
l'isolement les prisonniers ne
comprennent absolument pas ce qu'il a
fait mais là là on peut pas dire que la
justice a été rendu on peut pas dire du
tout que la justice a été rendu les
tribunaux sont là pour rendre justice au
nom du peuple français Géraldine tout à
l'heure a parlé de citoyens mais il y a
aucun citoyen qui conne ce que ce mec a
fait et qui est OK pour que ce gars a un
an en prison dans 1 an il va sortir il a
fait 15 infractions dans 1 an il va
sortir il va en faire une 16e et une 17e
et je te j'espère qu'un jour ça ne
t'arrivera jamais crois-mi tu sais à
quoi je pense tu sais à quoi je pense
moi je pense d'abord à la grand-mère et
sa peti et surtout à la grand-mère qui
dois dire ce gars-là dans un an il sera
dehors non mais vous rendez compte non
mais vous rendez compte ou pas non mais
non mais parce que elle elle elle est
traumatisée à vie elle elle a PR
perpétuité je te le dis non mais voilà
je te le dis à mon avis elle doit encore
avoir des séquelles là voilà je te le
dis l'image elle est incroyable de
violence mais lui elle va le croiser
dans la rue dans un an elle va aller
faire S et toi Gill toi tu dis que c'est
normal non non il d'abord il
aélo estce que ce mec là est-ce que ce
mec là arrête avec ça arrête avec
ça crois qu'il vont mettre un policier
derrière son cul crois quoi C mais il il
a pas de discernement le mec qu- tu
crois qu'il va dire ah non non c'est
vrai que non non j'ai une mesure
d'éloignement tu crois qu'il va avoir un
policier derrière son cul pour voir siil
s'éloigne de la grand-mère mais arrête
de dire mais arrête encore une fois Gill
mon chéri tu tu tu vis dans ton dans
l'utopie tu vois bien que le mec tu vois
bien que pour faire ça alors non mais
sais c'est ça qui est fou donc pour
faire ça ça pour faire ça il le fait
mais demain il vaement ah non non c'est
vrai non les gars je vais pas y aller
parce que attention j'ai une mesure des
loi devant regarde tu te rappelle ou pas
tu sa que j'ai une mesure mais mais mais
mais arrête un peu mais mais Gill mais
réfléchis 2 minutes s'il te plaît s'il
te plaît réfléchis 2 minutes je te
demand un pas toutes les mission mais au
moins 5 minutes non mais voilà non mais
je te le dis non mais attends attends
est-ce que ce mec là pour toi parce que
pour moi j'ai ma réponse il doit être
out de la société vot geste là out hors
de la société si c'est le condamné à
perpétu mais excusez-moi mais c'est de
la folie j'ai pas le code pénal là mais
si le si les réquisitions c'était 2 ans
de prison c'est parce que il méritait 2
ans 5 ans sans doute
plusiss pare pénal comme d'habite de
parler
avec bar des on peut pas condamner à
perpéé un gars comme ça éi non mais là
là en fait tu comprends tu comprends
rien l'émission en fait tu comprends
rien l'émission excuse-moi là excuse-moi
te dire tu ne comprends rien l'émission
je ne teande pas te parler tu vois bien
qu'on parle pas Jean-Michel mer quand il
parle il parle pas avec le code pénal
Daniel parle pas avec le code pénal r il
parle pas avec le code pénal on sait
bien non mais tu nous prends pour tu
crois qu'il y AC des guignoles autour de
la table tu crois qu'on travaille mais
tu crois qu'on tu crois qu'on est des
tebés on te demande de penser avec ta
tête non pas avec le code pénal
pense-toi pensoi penser à ce que V GAM
pas à perpét voilà je et donc si on
suite au raisonnement qui sousentend que
ce mec peut être réinséré dans la
société qu'est-ce que tu as envies qu'il
devienne est-ce que tu as envies qu'on
côtoie ce mec là qu'on travaille avec
lui qu'on le croise dans la rue qu'il
croise nos enfants nos amis no est-ce
que tu penses qu'il peut AC nous il a un
surcir renforcé avec des soins j'espère
qu'il suivra les soins et je crois en la
psychiatrie mais j'ai le droit quand
même Mo je vois moi je vois le regard de
cette petite fille do je vois le regard
de cette petite fille qui voit sa
grand-mère comme ça moi je vais te dire
ce mec là pour moi je suis désolé pour
moi ce mec là il y a pas d'espoir
excuse-moi de dire ça jette une pièce en
esppère ouais tu
Jes tu jettes une pièce en l'air en
disant ce mec là une fois qu'il aura
fait ses 8 mois il va faire une
formation de transport professionnel il
ira conduire un camion il rentrera dans
le droit chemin il fera rien de mal et
il sera tranquille moi quand je le vois
comme ça habillé comme il est habillé je
me dis il est foutu ce mec là je pour
moi c'est un marginal je vais même plus
loin je me demande même qui lui a dit de
faire ça ça se trouve c'est même
quelqu'un qui lui a dit va chercher la
je moi je deviens fou quand je le vois
là comme ça je me dis il est perdu lui
qu'est-ce qu'il a été faire un truc
comme ça je vais donner un aut truc moi
je vais donner un a truc il y a un gars
im il y a un mec qui a vu ça voilà il
arrive derrière il lui met une tané que
c'est très possible un mec qui boit ça
le mec qui prend le mec il va prendre
peut-être autant de prison que le gars
là très que tu rends compte donc non
mais est-ce que tu rend comp donc arrête
de nous parler arrête de nous parler de
ton code
pénal je vous dis mais si vous je n'ai
pas le code pénal si vous condamnez
cette personne à la perpétuité ça veut
dire que vous condamnez des dizaines des
centaines de milliers de personnes à la
perpété par
qu'est-ce que vous faites que vous fait
agression sur tentativ de kidnapping
c'est pas une agression ça c'est une
tentative de kidnapping sur une enfant
violence volontaire
sur
pas regarde mais regardez comme il
est
excusem fait tu comprends en fait g tu
fais exprès excuse-moi tu vois bien
attends mais il fait
exprès qu'est-ce qu'il te dit il te
parle pas de ce qu'il y a sur le PV ou J
non mais
par c'est pour en
faireation il te demand pas de
F de
[Musique]
F
regarde et je me dis si la fille fait
pas demi-tour si lui change pas d'avis
si flipe pas parce
qu' grandmère pas ils vont dans une C
puis il est parti dans une C au
supermarché
Tom mavaise qualification parce
que parle pas français ce qui
interrogeill ce qui interroge c'est que
au de la vidéo et pourtant on n pas
juriste on se pose la question de cette
qualification qui est juste violence
volontaire alors qu'on peut imagine on
le voit prendre l'enfant et on imagine
qu'il y a aussi tenttive dans par
exemple à minima cette tentative
d'enlèvement elle est pas parTenu ça
c'est pas de ma faute
qualifationfend tu défend ce qu'ils ont
retenu miracle ils ont retenu parce
qu'ils ont bossé le dossier il a été
bossé les mec non mais Jean-Michel
jeanmicheli moi moi je peux plus lui
parler dir qui comprend pas le français
non mais parlelui toi parlelui toi s' PL
il va te parler tu vois quand même tu
vois quand même que c'est un jeune je
sais pas quel âge il une vingtaine 30
ans 15 qu'on a nation c'est 15 fois où
il a été chopé il a déjà eu faire plein
d'autres choses tu nas jamais été pris
donc c'est quelqu'un qui a un dossier un
casi judiciaire qui est long comme deux
bras l'un à côté de l'autre comme ça et
le mec là tu vois tu tu vois cro encore
qu'il y a une forme de rédemp quand il
va sortir au bout de 6 mois qui va
devenir un homme
génux quelquun qui pourriture pour la
société il faut l'écarter qu'est-ce que
tu veux faire c'est quoi le problème de
mettre en prison mais l'écartter ça veut
dire
quoi
perpéuit constr combien de centaines de
milliers de plac de
prison des g que
mettre ce V dire c'est que bien sûr
personne ne mérite de se faire agresser
mais il y a des gens ils ont quand même
minimum d'thque et lui il pas d' gen il
y en a qui vont pas toucher des enfants
lui tou âes sensible c'estd il prend les
enfants les femmes âées que là il peut
faire tout n'importe quoi tu ce mec là
ce mec là qu'est-ce que tu as dit moi
j'ai dit j'en veux pas moi ce mec je pas
après je suis d'accord avec est-ce que
perpét est-ce qu'il faut pas changer les
lois moi je suis pas d'accord par que
dis- 4 5 6 ans peut-être qu'il faut le
soigner vraiment réellement mais ce mec
là pour moi j'ai j'ai pas d'avenir pour
moi parce que c'est pas c'est pas une
agress c'est pas une bagarre il essaie
d'eneverion desur RP
c'est tout sauf l'humanistme c'est
l'inversion des valeurs non mais ça
c'est on peut discuter de ça cyil c'est
intelligent ça mais mais moi mes valeurs
c'est de dire qu'il y a une gradation et
que lui oh là là oh là là ah oui mais et
on te demande pas de pas mais écoute-moi
si on avait besoin de quelqu'un on a non
non non écoute-moi av besoin d'un homme
de loi on aurait on aura un homme de loi
autour de la table c'est pas ce qu'on
cherche non mais c'est pas ce qu'on
cherche dis y moi je vous dis alors avec
ma tête avec mon cœur avec tout ce que
voulez avec mon cul je vous le dis il
mérite pas d'aller en prison à VI alors
je pense que tu dis qu'avec ton cul il y
a une gradation qu'est-ce qu'il y a de
pire à part un meurtre que quelqu'un qui
veut s'en prendre une
petite ça mais d'accord tu mets pas 2
ans tu tu mets pas 6 mois de
prison mais écoute-moi bien tu as pas
compris qu'il a eu de la chance cet
abruti là cet abruti là par ça abruti il
il a eu de la chance en fait parce que
il a eu il a eu de chance que avec la
violence elle aurait déc elle aurait pu
décéder la donc donc donc donc en fait
toi c'est tu jettes une pièce il a
raison tiens tu sais quoi on jette une
pièce on attend ah non c'est bon chance
parce ça ça c'est tentative de Meur ça
c'est tentative de Meur tentative
d'homicide et enlèvement d'un mineur
enlèvement d'un
enfant c'est déjà bien moi je suis
content pant 10 Mo la grandmère au moins
pendant la grandmère pendant 10 ans est
tranquille parce que la grand-mère là
elle y pense tu crois pas là nous nous
on fait les malins ici sur le plateau
mais moi je pense à la grand-mère qui
nous regarde la grand-mère la grand-mère
qui nous regarde qui se dit moi je vais
pas aller chercher moi je plus faire mes
courses tranquilles maintenant elle est
elle est traumatisée vie elle fait plus
ses courses comme avant qu'elle a vécu
là et la petite aussi bien sûr je pense
à choqu qui serait choqué qu'il fasse 10
ans autour de personne moi qui serait
choqué qu' fasse 10 ans ici personne
mais il y a que lui qui est choqué de
tout mais non mais vous diriez 10 ans
c'est pas
assez on t dit au moins 10 ans qu'on est
en train de te dire e tu sais quoi toi
tu es toujours en train d'anticiper les
problèmes qu'il n'y a pas là on est en
train de te dire que 1 an c'est trop peu
et lui il est en train de N dire ouais
mais sil y avait eu 10 ans c'est tropé
écoute-moi bien tu sais quoi c'est c'est
la technique en fait de tu sais quoi de
Languille tu vois ou pas on lui dit 1 an
c'est passé dit ouis mais 10 ans
même s'il avait rien fait avant on
t'aurait dit bon mais 15 condamnation
avant c'està dire que même avant il a
fait quelque chose c'estd que là on lui
dit allez ressort dans 8 mois et
recommence tes conneries moi je pense
surtout aux gens que lui il va être
dehors dans 8 mois peut-être qu'il va
s'attaquer à un petit d'entre nous c'est
ça que je pense moi quand les gens dis
Gill ver c'est la défense des agresseurs
des délincants on dirait qu'il ne pens
jamais au vraie victimes qu'est-ce que
vous répondz mais non mais je suis pour
qu'il aille en prison mais
cy excusez-moi et je suis d'accord sur
toutes les critiques et tout ça mais là
c'est sorte de procès d'intention je
suis je suis moi je suis soulagé que par
un miracle psychiatrique et judiciaire
ce type odieux abant so en prison bah
oui mais je vous dis tous tes arguments
sont Malonn habituellement tu en as rien
à [__] du code pénal tu passes ton
temps à défoncer le code
pénal mais tu ces derrière un argument
qui est malonnte tu te ces derère tu te
casses derrière le code pénal mon pote
c'est absolument malhonnête non il bien
que Al déjà c'est pas ton
poteou ton pote ton pote est-ce que tes
amis c'est tes amis non c'est pas mes
amis et c'est pas mon pote c'est plus
mes amis que lui et mon
pote tes amis tes amis je pense qu'ils
pensent comme toi tu vois ou pas tes
amis pensent comme toi et c'est bizarre
parce que à chaque fois tu penses
exactement comme tes amis c'est fou
pourtant c'est pas j'ai pas entendu
arguments làdessus moi je te dis qu'
pens comme toi alors je te le dis c'est
S comme G a bossé qui connait le dossier
les 15 condamnations il y a donc dél
routi mais il y a eu quoi d'autre dans
et est-ce qu'il a déjà été en prison
pour ces 15 condamnations je l'ignore
personnellement déjà j'aimerais bien
savoir quand on a 15 condamnations en
France aujourd'hui avec du stup avec des
délires est-ce qu'on déjà on fait un
tout petit peu de prison ou déjà pas du
tout qui déjà sera un très très mauvais
signal de chance on lui a laissé sa
chance je pense 15 condamnations il y a
des gens ils aimeraient bien avoir la
chance d'avoir 15 condamnations qu'ils
ont pas eu je pense que le souci c'est
qu'il se met plus à la place des
agresseurs que à la place des victimes
il se met jamais à la place des victimes
parce que si toi demain ça arrive bien
sû tuas demand plus 10 ans bien s tu
demand
plus on est d'accord pas dire ça tu si
toi ça t'arrive tu as demandé combien de
temps bien
SAS pas
réponduans doute que j'agir et là sous
la dit le coup de la dictature de
l'motion et j'espère que j'aurais du
recul mais j'en aurais pas vous savez
très bien mais ça je suis honte recul
attends le recul c'est de laissé en
liberté de dire le recul j'espère que
pas en liberté il est en prison mais
vous sort dans un an il s il ne mérite
pas de sortir dans un an vous vous ne
voulez pas qu'il sorte et en fait
personne veut l'avouer vous vous êtes
pour oui 10 an oui c'est pas ce que vous
avez dit c'est pas ce que vous avez dit
vous avez dit H d'état de nuire et dans
10 ans pourquoi il irait mieux que dans
un an
expliquez-moi
il a raison regardez le sonage regardez
le sonage dans 5 ans on sera pas plus
tranquille voilà bon ben voilà voilà
donc voilà 5 % à mon avis c'est Gill qui
a dû voter CIN fois voilà donc ça se
passé comme ça euh les